as ice deportation more an ice  deportation warrant is not the same as a  search warrant if that is the only  document ice brings to a home raid  agents do not have the legal right to  enter a home if ice agents don't have a  warrant warrant signed by a judge a  person may refuse to open the door and  let them in an administrative order of  removal from ice or immigration  authorities is simply not enough  families belong together everyone in our  country has rights many of these  families are mixed status families we  hope the president would pray but the  president will think about this I would  say again hopefully it's again